hello everyone my name is chinhui and i
would like to talk about how do we
design functional data pipelines for
reproducibility and maintainability
okay so
a little bit of myself i'm chinchi um
i'm a data engineer at dt one uh so it's
a fintech company so we did mainly deal
with
digital transit
communication transactions so i come
from a background in aerospace
engineering and competition
computational modeling and also my day
job i am also a speaker and i
occasionally write about data processing
so when we talk about a data pipeline
right um
so this it
starts off something simple we have an
input
we have a process or operation
and then we have an output so in this
case our operation is whereby we create
a circle that fits a particular shape
and so this is sick so we have the
extract the data extra input we
transform and then we have the output so
it looks pretty easy right
turns out it's
if we were to design your data pipeline
skill it
tends to be a little bit tricky because
when we design a data pipeline sql we
need to consider three things
firstly it has to be reliable what we
mean is that
data pipeline must produce the desired
output which leads us to the issue of
reproducibility
it also has to be scalable
which means that the data pipeline must
run independently across multiple nodes
which links us to the concept of
parallelism
and last but not least
because when we design our data partner
at scale we didn't expect that there
will be changing business logic so we
need to be able to design the data
pipeline such that we can extend it
without much disruption and this links
us to the topic of maintainability
and what are the challenges when we are
designing data partners at scale
so let's start off with developing the
data pipeline
during the testing phase so typically we
when we develop the the tether logic for
their pipeline during the testing phase
we need to
consider whether we can get reproducible
results so let's take an example of a
processing and approving loads so we
have our late loan request and if we
want to determine whether we want to
approve the loans we will need to look
at the customer credit rating so
determine whether the customer is
trustworthy and so with so we have the
data source we have our cooperation and
what we are achieving what we are trying
to achieve is the target which is the
approved loads
and
when we decide when we design the data
pipeline we need to ensure that
with the same data source
with the same competition logic
even if i run it three months later
it has to be
getting the same output but can we
ensure that when we are designing the
data pipeline doing the testing place
so when we will consider how to actually
design whether we can get it in the
reproducible manner we need to consider
what are the dependencies of the output
in the data pipeline design so when we
look at the data pipeline the main
dependencies are the data source as well
as the computation logic
so those two those two dependencies are
the ones that we have to manage to
determine whether whatever pipeline that
we're designing is reproducible before
we move into production
so the challenge is that given the same
data source how do we ensure that we
replicate the same result every time we
rewrite the same process because
if we have the same data source and we
have the same measure logic we need to
ensure that there is no random factor
that will affect whatever result you get
because
let's say it's for compliance reasons we
need to ensure that whatever whatever
output that we have has to be the same
every time we run the same pipeline
so now now that we have gone through the
testing and we assured everything's fine
so we need so we deploy the pipeline to
production
but we also need to ensure that whatever
we develop is also reproducible in
production and
when we are going to scale right whereby
we start deploying this pipeline so even
into more notes
for more transitions so let's say we
would like to compute the margins for
the sales transactions
so typically
each transaction will be associated with
a certain cost so at a certain margin
and because they are different because
they are they are reliant on the
transaction itself row by row so we can
chunk them we compute the margins across
multiple nodes and then we collect the
results into an output so this is what
we did but so
typically if we typically if we have a
process that is
suitable for parallelism and easily
parallelizable parallelizable then it
shouldn't be much of a problem
but what if we have this particular
scenario whereby we have a data source
which is
probably going to keep training state
after after each processing complete
such as
if we are trying to perform transaction
requests and we need to check whether
there's enough balance in the inventory
and in this
case
whether you have enough balance in the
inventory for each transaction depends
on the order in which the transactions
are being processed and so this is time
dependent
and
if you want to be able to replicate the
result
then
the question is that what is the current
state of the data source because
if what with the currency of the data
source is time dependent and it keeps
changing then
it poses some challenges in terms of
debugging
debugging at run time due to the shared
states when you are running parallel and
co-current code
and so the challenge is that how do we
design data pipelines that run the same
combination logic across multiple nodes
and reproduce predictable results every
time
because
because we need to be able to ensure
that in order for it to be reliable and
reproducible in production
and now that i've actually talked about
reversibility and not next up i talked
about maintainability during debugging
because once you have deployed your
pipeline in production
something might happen because when
whatever that works the testing
might actually break the production
because
when we are designed because when we are
designing a test when developing a data
pipeline there might be certain age
cases and inefficiencies that are not
accounted for or not detected in the
test cases which actually shows up
and causing performance issues or
failures in production because
typically when we detect test cases they
will be on a smaller data set and
we and we might not be able to cover
every single age case
of the data that we have in production
and to complicate things further there
are are certain complexities in
debugging and logging for parallelism
because we need to keep track of because
if we want to do logging on different
clusters then we also need to know which
like
which processes which process in which
cos which cluster is having some issues
and it can get really complicated when
you are actually running the process
so the challenge is that how do we
maintain design data pipelines that are
readable and maintainable at its core to
reduce inefficiencies in production
debugging and skill because we can't
count on us we can't count on
debugging as we go and in the production
system so we need to ensure that what
that if there is any issue that surfaces
we should be able to identify what are
what is the bug in the call in the code
that is causing those issues
and when as we add new features to an
evolving goal code base because of
changing business logic
the code reasoning actually becomes more
challenging with increasing code
complexity and when you add new members
who are narrow to the code base and you
add even more new features that have
certain dependencies there also raise
the risk of introducing unintended
behavior due to those dependencies
so the challenge that we have when
adding new features in terms of
maintainability is
how do we design data pipelines that
adapts well to changing business and
technical requirements and
ensures developer productivity
and how do we do that and this brings me
to the concept of designing data
pipelines as functions
and also and this also brings us to the
topic of functional programming so what
is functional programming
it is actually a declarative style
programming that emphasizes writing
software using only pure functions and
immutable values and so for that i will
actually elaborate a little bit more on
the definition
and
and the three key principles of partial
programming is that we need to have we
design using pure functions and we try
to avoid side effects secondly
immutability is a core principle and
last but not least so for functional
programming to be able to work we need
to ensure referential transparency
and what do we how do we define the pure
function
well a pure function is where the output
depends on what input number two
internal algorithm and
pretty much nothing else and secondly it
must have no side effects so it should
not be
influencing anything outside of the
function itself
and
when the implication of the concept of
pure function is that
if we have the same function
we have the same input parameter we have
the same internal algorithm we should be
expecting the same result with
regardless of the number of invocations
and now that i've mentioned about pure
functions as side effects let's
illustrate the concept of pure function
with an example let's say we like to
make pizza and so for pizza we have our
ingredients of course we also have
pineapples because i love pineapples we
put all them together into a nice
unbaked pizza and put it in others so
the advert is your function and we set
certain parameters at 160 degrees
celsius at 10 minutes and we should be
expecting a nice toasted pizza
and so this is what we expect as a pure
function
in reality making pizza is an impure
function because it causes side effects
so some of the side effects will include
radiation heat immunity like from the
oven
so that's it so you're actually
affecting something in the environment
and it's not in within the oven itself
or another slight effect could be that
your oven overheats and ends up changing
your parameter from 160 degree celsius
to 180 degrees celsius and you end up
with a burnt pizza
and this is not pizza you see
and if we look at a more formal
definition in the context of designing a
pipeline a function of site effects
changes state outside of the functional
local function scope which is the oven
so some examples that common could be
while modifying a variable
or it could be local global state it
could be performing an io operation
whereby you're reading files or equals
withdrawing exception errors such as
having a bunch of pizza
let's know
now that i've talked about pure function
which to go into the concept of
immutability so the concept of
immutability is that once i instantiate
a variable and i assign a value to the
variable
i cannot assign another i cannot
reassign another another value to get
that particular variable
and and the implication of because of
every immutability of an assign variable
is that it enforces a certain level of
disability state management
and prevents side effects withdrawing
from state change
which links which enables us to design
our data pipelines using pure functions
the key implication of the concept of
immutability is that it makes it writing
parallel and concurrent programs much
easier because now that i know that my
data source it's not going to change and
i can't change it
so
so i don't need to keep tracking the
state of my up my input and i can focus
on partitioning my input and focusing on
the computation knowing that my my data
source is not going to change during the
process
and last but not least we'll talk about
trans respiration transparency
so reference respiratory transparency is
such that if i have an expression and
then i have a result and
they are pretty they are pretty much so
i can actually substitute that
expression with the result
so the formal definition of referential
transparency is that a function is
referentially transparent when an
expression can be substituted by this
equivalent algorithm without affecting
the program logic for all programs so
so for the example of substituting the
square function with x sub x it's pretty
much equivalent
and the conditions for referential
transparency would be a fail function
besides the pure function it also has to
be deterministic such that the
expression always returns the same
output given the same input and so let's
look at this illustration for uh
well what do we mean by deterministic
but not deterministic so for a
deterministic process let's say i would
like to make breakfast i like to make
toast so
i should be expecting that for every
time i want to make toast i put a bread
in the oven i should be getting toast
regardless of when i make the toast
however a non-terminating process is
such that
maybe what three months later i tried to
make toast with bread and somehow i
ended up with bird toast which is not
equal to toast
and this means that the other big the
other process it's did none
deterministic and depend on time
and now uh now we have pure function
with deterministic and last but not
least there's also the concept of age
potency such that the expression can be
applied multiple times without changing
the result beyond its initial
application so once i run the pipeline
once the second time third time fourth
time hundredth time it should not be
changing the result
and an example of angel portals can be
expected will be the absolute function
whereby i apply it when i apply an
absolute function to a negative number
if i keep applying the result i should
still get a positive number
and and the key consequence of
referential transparency that is that
the expression can be replaced with this
equivalent result so in this case
i in this case i can i can actually
reason it much easier because i can i
can equate i can equate the square
function with the x of x whether i have
other elements in the in the in the
pipeline
now they've talked about functional
programming and the concept and the
people's mode let's go to functional
control flow
how we design functional control flow is
true function composition so i can
compose my functions and like such that
the output of the function can be the
input of another function and and i can
and it is equal it's still equivalent it
can be equivalent to another function
and in python functions are first-class
objects such that a function can be
assigned the variable passes the
parameters of other functions and return
its value from other functions and this
is
this is actually important when we are
talking about writing functional
data pipelines
because the key consequence of first
class functions is that we can write
higher order functions
such that we can accept functions as
parameters and return a function as
value which is what we are using we are
trying to do for function composition
and and a related concept with anonymous
functions also known as lambda
expressions in python such that instead
such that such that for simpler
expressions we can use the function as
input without defining the name function
object so hence we can save a bit of
space in terms of creating the function
and we can use the function as it is as
a lambda expression
and some examples of
such high order functions are mapped
whereby i met whereby i met each element
in the collection with a function
they have a filter whereby we have a
predicate we reached which has a true
force motif and then whatever the
fulfills the predicate will be
will be actually selected from those
collections
and last but not least we also have
reducer by we actually compose all the
all the all the elements of the
collection into a single output
and when we compare the news on bad
filter radius was as follow one one
thing that we can notice is that for for
for loop we need to manage state change
of a mutable variable
well that is not the case for um for
using for the use of
bad filter reduce
and the related concept of function
composition is the recursion because
recursion is effectively a form of
self-referential function composition
because it takes the result of itself as
input into another instance of itself
and we can also consider it as a form of
functional iteration however we can't
keep going on forever so to prevent e
for that recursive loop our base case is
required as a terminal condition
and this is a this is an illustration of
what is the first particular because it
calls thing and it recalls it and you
guys you can see for because it caused
the ex it ends up taking out much more
space called between iterative causes
whereby even though you do not have uh
even though you
even so because provocative crosstalk we
are assuming that there are we are we
are actually calling and calling on
colleague and we are actually ended up
having
a stack based on the number of codes
that we make but for the iterative call
stack we only have one step because we
are we are changing but we are
constantly changing the value
throughout the for loop
and and to write and to resolve this we
have the causal tail called optimization
which aims to reduce that flip
composition consumption in the call
state but what the telecoil does is
basically when it sees the pattern and
then it and then it identifies that
and converts them to iterative loop so
that
so that whatever so that the tail call
does nothing other than just returning
the value of the function call hence you
do not end up with uh
with a very high stack frame when you
are doing a recursion
so something like this so
when i see the pattern i just cover it
as an iterative look in the compiler and
that is the case for some programming
regulators such as scala and maybe like
other high scale and other functional
programming languages
and now that i've actually talked a bit
more about those concepts and how do we
actually do the iteration and how the
control flow let's go on to the
functional design patterns for the data
pipeline design
and when we have much and when i
mentioned about immutability we
brings us to the topic of immutable data
structures such because so because an
immutable data structure is such that
once it is created it cannot be changed
and the benefits are numerous it is
easier to reason because what you see is
what you get it is easier to test
because i don't need to worry so much
about the state changes i can focus on
the logic when i'm designing a pipeline
and last but not least the main benefit
is that it is tragic and it is easier
for parallelism
in some some of the examples of dinosaur
immutable data structures in python uh
let's say the toolbar so in the case of
all this i can change the okay i can
change the i can change the element in
the in the collection
but that's not the case for jupiter
if you want instead of instantiating a
class to define a certain
data type
or a dictionary
which are mutable
why not consider using a name tuple such
that you cannot set and cannot reset an
attribute after you have instantiated an
instance on your name tuple
but technically if you try to you could
use the underscore replace but you
realize that what this function actually
does is creating a new instance of that
of a point
of power name tuple instead of replacing
the original point named tuple
and now i've talked about data
structures let's talk about the
algorithms and strata transformations
and how and we can use map filter in
data transformation such as to sort it
we can filter the number and then we do
our mapping of mapping to mapping of a
collection to
a certain function
and using map filter as derivatives in
data transformation allows us to keep
the data and transformation logic
separate and because it ensures as it's
interesting we can reuse the function
that we are actually using the map
filter it improves code reasonability
and we also have better transparency of
the transformation logic because if we
look at we can look clearly based on the
function itself that we are
mapping each of the elements of the
color in a collection using a function
to an output
and we can extend this concept of map
filter to parallel and calculate
programming
and you can use multi-processing you can
also use a
co-current filters so this is this is
actually something that's that's from
another talk
okay so we can also do we can also
perform some data actions and
aggregations so for example reduce
okay reduce is not uh it's not ability
function but it like this is still
important for computers so we had so
what you just does is that if i have i
have a function that i'll compose with
an iterable what i do is that i compose
those values bit by bit so instead of
you know 40 and 40 and 40 40 i think we
have a single result
and using reviews and its narratives and
data access and aggregations it shows
that when we design our data pipelines
we focus on the transformations first
which is a map filter and that before we
do our aggregations we stop actions and
the transformation logic can be so why
do we what is it so because we know that
the transformation logic can be applied
to each element of partition while the
actions or aggregations consolidate
consolidates without partitions through
composing those results
and
now that i talked about that i've got
transformation actions then i i will
have to talk about arbitrary stock which
uses resilient distributed data sets as
a low level data abstraction
and this is related to functional
programming because the rdds are
immutable read only and
because and because of that and this
this is a very important consideration
in terms of designing for tolerant
parallel operations because you have
immutability you also have logical
partitioning and so this makes this and
this is the re and this is the main
abstraction behind spark and why we can
run parallel operations with that
and so uh so similarly we have
transformations
and uh
five minute mark have five minutes left
by the way quick reminder
okay
yeah so so we've also already learned
more transformations in opportunities
but we have a data set we transformed
into a new data set or rdd
and for actions we learned that a
dataset or rdd is transformed into an a
non-rdd result so this is actually
similar to what i've actually mentioned
about transformations versus actions
for
and in relation to map filter reduce
and
since we are at python 3.10 now i have
to mention a bit about structural
pattern matching which is inspired by a
similar syntax scala and this is
especially useful for conditional
matching of data structure patterns so
um this is so it is pretty simple you
have a match up your method item and you
look through all those cases and it
matches
a certain case you'll do something
and
this is this is
this is particularly useful if you
during replacing certain matching in
terms of data types whether it's an
instance of a certain data type so
before private 3.10 we have to rely on
if and leave that else and now with
python 3.10
we if we look at the code on the left it
looks pretty much more straightforward
because we are matching the structure of
the data
and this and and this and the
implication of using structural pattern
matching is that it ensures it enables
us to maintain the data schema in a
cleaner manner
and so for example right we are for
example we are using
uh data class which is similar to case
classes in scala
and so you can see that
so you can see clearly that we have
those two there are class types and
i'm matching based on which type it
belongs to
it is in terms of the structure
and to complete this talk um we also
need to mention a little bit about type
systems because python although it does
not it doesn't have static it does not
it's not that's not street typing it
does have support for type hints
although it's not enforcing runtime
and and how we can enforce that is
through type checking with my pi
and
which can be used in together with the
type heads
so you can see that if the types are
wrong you're going to show up with type
error and this ensures your type
checking
and why is it so important to enforce
certain type checking in when developing
your data pipeline is because it
prevents bugs at runtime by ensuring
type safety and consistency across data
data pipeline because you want to be
very sure nothing very transparent about
the data type but very very transparent
by the data and we want to be able to
design their products that it
and it actually considers all those
factors in consideration especially at
scale
so now that i've actually talked about
all the data
patterns can we write a purely
functional data pipeline python
cheshire answer is not really
because we need to consider that we
still have to have we still need io
operations for reading and writing data
outside of the application domain
and so this brings me to the another
design pattern called functional core
imperative shell which is inspired which
is basically based on gary the heart's
pipe on 2030 token boundaries so the
idea is that you keep the repeat the
core domain transformation logic
as a function call
and then we leave the infrastructure
code separate from this functional call
so that we can interface with our data
and an example of the of using
functional call informative shell can be
shown in this example so we have the io
layer to read the data we have the
functional layer for the computation
logic and lastly we end off this program
with an io layer to write the data
outside of the program
and so the key takeaways for this talk
is that
like when we are designing data
pipelines at scale
it is advisable to adopt functional
design patterns
for especially when especially about
looking at parallel and distributed
workflows because we need to consider
that when we are designing at scale it
needs to be reproducible scalable and
maintainable and while we can't design
an entire a purely functional program we
can adopt a functional called imperative
shell design pattern to manage site
effects separately from the data
pipeline logic
and that's the end of my talk we hope
don't reach out to me via the following
channels and i'm currently writing a
algorithm functional programming so do
check it out
thank you
you